[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute mit mitri
sirin ihnen allen einen schönen guten
abend an diesem 7 dezember bringen wir
sie wieder auf den stand der dinge
natürlich tun würde sofort ich mit katja
stresow angel guten hand dann blicken
wir auf die schlagzeilen des tages
unter dach und fach die ampel parteien
unterschreiben ihren koalitionsvertrag
und erklären ihre pläne
schlagabtausch im bundestag die künftige
regierung wird für eine impfpflicht für
einzelne berufsgruppen
und hoffen auf deeskalation die
präsidenten putin und beiden reden
miteinander über den konflikt in der
ukraine
[Musik]
bevor morgen der kanzler und die neue
ministerriege vereidigt werden bevor
also morgen im bundestag wahrscheinlich
auch große emotionen einzug halten ging
es heute eigentlich um etwas formales um
unterschriften unterschriften der ampel
parteien unter die
177 seiten koalitionsvertrag wie das
ablief und was dazu erklärt wurde
christiane hübscher
das nennt man wohl geschichte schreiben
13 unterschriften besiegelten den ersten
rot grün gelben vertrag auf bundesebene
gut zehn wochen nach der bundestagswahl
am morgen seien bei dem wir aufbrechen
zu einer neuen regierung jetzt beginnt
die zeit der tat und es geht jetzt
diesen koalitionsvertrag mit weitblick
mit pragmatismus und vor allen dingen
auch mit viel leidenschaft mit leben zu
füllen mehr fortschritt wagen haben sie
sich als überschrift verordnet acht
ministerinnen gehören der neuen
regierung an mehr als je zuvor auf der
folgenden pressekonferenz aber sitzen
wieder nur drei männer ab morgen müssen
sie zuallererst die pandemie bekämpfen
die korona protest der verunsichern den
kanzler ins b nicht die gesellschaft ist
eben nicht gespalten sondern überwiegend
einer meinung und natürlich gibt es
einige die anderer meinung sind dass es
in ordnung und gibt es von diesen wieder
ein teil des
aggressiv agiert davon darf aber die
ganze gesellschaft sich nicht anstecken
lassen der neue wirtschafts und
klimaminister will die
ausbaugeschwindigkeit erneuerbarer
energien mindestens verdreifachen und
wird das land auf eine große
transformation ein dass an der stelle
sagen dass bei allen sonntagsreden die
es immer gibt für mehr klimaschutz und
irgendwie sind alle für erneuerbare
energien das nicht ohne zumutungen zu
haben sein wollt wir werden viel
miteinander als land als gesellschaft zu
diskutieren haben wenn wir diese ziele
umsetzen wollen und es ist ein
langstreckenlauf die finanzierung der
vorhaben ist nach wie vor wenig
transparent der nächste finanzminister
dennoch zuversichtlich die aufgabe in
den nächsten vier jahren wird es sein zu
ermöglichen dass die öffentlichen
vorhaben für den klimaschutz als auch
die privaten transformations- aufgaben
realisiert werden können morgen 9 uhr
will olaf scholz zum kanzler gewählt
werden und dann beginnt das regieren
neue koalition neuer koalitionsvertrag
und weitere neue personalien carsten
schneider bislang parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer der spd wird neuer
beauftragter für die ostdeutschen
bundesländer schneider ist aus thüringen
und seiner aufgabe ist ab jetzt im
kanzleramt angesiedelt neu auch die
spitze der grünen fraktion wird künftig
von frauen geführt von britta haßelmann
vorher parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin und der wirtschaft
expertin katharina dröge und die
fdp-fraktion die wählte finanzpolitiker
christian job zum neuen vorsitzenden
die meisten personalien sind also
geklärt der koalitionsvertrag besiegelt
was die ampel regierung für deutschland
plant zum beispiel finanzpolitisch im
klimaschutz oder in der außenpolitik all
das können sie nachlesen bei zdf heute
beziehungsweise in unserer heute
es ist schon ein novum dass eine
bundesregierung in spe schon so aktiv
mitmischt bevor es überhaupt richtig
losgeht vor zweieinhalb wochen haben die
ampel parteien im bundestag für die
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
geworben und auch gestimmt
und jetzt steht schon wieder die
nachschärfung an über die reform der
reform und die heutige sondersitzung im
parlament jetzt heike slansky
es ist sein letzter tag als vizekanzler
da müssen seine ampel parteien bereits
zum zweiten mal in wenigen wochen ihr
infektionsschutzgesetz nachschärfen auch
deshalb appelliert er wohl in seiner
neuen rolle als künftiger
gesundheitsminister an den zusammenhalt
wir dürfen die bürger nicht verunsichern
dass wir instrumente abgegeben hätten
für lange zeit werden wir diese
instrumente benötigen dann werden wir
sie hier im parlament sofort einsetzen
doch die union beharrt weiterhin auf der
epidemischen notlage die nach der wahl
abgeschafft wurde und treibt die ampel
in die defensive sie schließen lücken
und versuchen lücken zu schließen die
sie selber aufgerissen haben sie handeln
zu spät und sie handeln zu wenig die
grünen konnten
im sommerwind die zweijährigen gewesen
in diesem land wo im sommer wurde die
buskampagne vorbereitet besonders die
liberalen stehen nun mit der
beabsichtigten impfpflicht fürs personal
in gesundheitsberufen ab märz in der
kritik seit jeher war für uns der
schutzhülle gruppen besonders wichtig
deswegen aus dieser verantwortung heraus
fordern wir dass alle menschen die in
den entsprechenden einrichtungen
arbeiten geimpft sein müssen die afg
lehnt sowohl eine impfpflicht als auch
corona beschränkungen
diese abermalige verschärfung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ist vor allem
eins ein epochaler wortbruch und
wahlbetrug sie haben den bürgern vor der
wahl etwas ganz anderes versprochen im
eilverfahren will die ampel ihr gesetz
durchpeitschen die linke empört
ein grundrechtseingriff innerhalb von
vier tagen
bereits am freitag soll das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz verabschiedet
werden
ja so viel zum schlagabtausch über
corona im bundestag jetzt die aktuellen
zahlen die sinken leicht meldet heute
das robert koch institut allerdings
werden wohl viele fälle nicht pünktlich
gemeldet weil gesundheitsämter und
kliniken regional überlastet sind binnen
eines tages wurden 36.000 59
neuinfektionen registriert
9600 94 weniger als vor einer woche
399 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents liegt jetzt bei 4
132,2 in brandenburg da sind die zahlen
noch deutlich schlechter das land will
die epidemische notlage ausrufen und es
verzeichnet die bundesweit
zweitschlimmste impfquote
intensivmediziner warnen und fürchten
bis weihnachten eine kaum zu
bewältigende auslastung meine kollegin
nicola albrecht war wieder auf einer
intensivstation in senftenberg und hat
dieser wichtige szenen erlebt weder
pflegerin sleeping noch wir hätten
gedacht dass wir uns fast genau nach
einem jahr hier auf der intensivstation
im klinikum niederlausitz wieder sehen
würden wieder herrscht ausnahmezustand
wieder sterben hier fast täglich
patienten
emotional hat sich nichts verändert dass
es immer noch ein ganz furchtbares
gefühl die patienten in die leichensäcke
zulegen die klinik liegt im coebad
hotspot südbrandenburg wo die instanz
zwischen 1200 und 1500 liegt die meisten
patienten sind ungeimpft aber auch
menschen mit schwachem immunsystem die
keine auffrischung erhalten haben
kämpfen hier um ihr leben besucht werden
dürfen sie nicht oberarzt thomas
schneider informiert die angehörigen
telefonisch
patienten verlegen aus fliegen dorthin
wo es noch kapazitäten gibt ist nun auch
wieder alltag die betten sind
phasenweise überbelegt ausschließlich
durch kurve patienten das bedeutet wir
machen ja eine sogenannte strategische
ab verlegung alleine damit wir uns
unsere hand die fähigkeit erhalten
könnte die prognose für die region es
werden bis weihnachten noch deutlich
mehr patienten habe tatsächlich angst
vor weihnachten ich habe angst vor dem
was uns noch erwarten wird die klinik
hat vorsorglich das ethik-komitee
zusammengerufen drei teams werden
gebildet die müssen dann im ernstfall
entscheiden wer ein intensiv bett
bekommt und wer nicht
jetzt zu einem schweren konflikt von
weltpolitischer bedeutung die ukraine
sie will sich westlich orientieren und
rein in eu und nato russland will das ja
unbedingt verhindern das alarmiert auch
us-präsident beiden heute hat er die
lage in einem video gipfel mit präsident
putin besprochen aber nochmal zum
hintergrund schon seit mehr als sieben
jahren tobte im osten der ukraine einen
bürgerkrieg die separatisten dort werden
von moskau unterstützt und zuletzt hatte
russland auf seiner seite der grenze an
mehreren stellen militär zusammengezogen
ein pulverfass christian senn berichtet
hallo gut dass wir uns wiedersehen sagt
joe biden
hallo herr präsident antwortete putin
sie sprechen miteinander alleine das
wird schon als gutes zeichen gewertet
ein video gipfel erzwungen von wladimir
putin durch den russischen
truppenaufmarsch an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze viele
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer wie hier
heute in kiew haben angst vor einem
russischen angriff
niemand weiß was im kopf von putin vor
geht nicht einmal gott
das einzige was wir tun können ist für
den frieden zu beten ich verfolge nicht
wirklich alles aber das ist mein land
ich lebe hier und mache mir sorgen
bereits im frühjahr provozierte russland
in den augen der nato als es sein
militär an der grenze zur ukraine
zusammen zog jetzt passiert es wieder
dazu hält das militär noch ein winter
manöver in der ukrainischen grenzregion
ab vortreffliche gelegenheit für neue
provokationen
die ukraine will die nato putin will das
verhindern für moskau ist die nato
osterweiterung eine rote linie die
wiederum von den usa nicht akzeptiert
wird
mit der konzentration der truppen an der
grenze versucht putin vor allem
militärischen politischen und
psychologischen druck nicht auf die
ukraine sondern auf beiden auszuüben das
ist ein versuch aus einer position der
stärke heraus zu verhandeln ein versuch
beiden mit dem krieg in der ukraine zu
erpressen
große erwartungen an den video gipfel
gab es insgesamt nicht zwei stunden
redeten putin und beiden miteinander zu
beginn hatte der us präsident noch
gesagt dass er hoffe putin bald wieder
persönlich zu treffen zu besprechen gibt
es ja immer noch genug
claudia bates ist für uns in washington
claudia wie stehen denn die chancen auf
eine entspannung in der ukraine nach
diesem treffen
also erpressen lassen will präsident
biden sich nicht das hat er mehr als
deutlich im vorfeld gesagt ein
ansatzpunkt für eine diplomatische
lösung könnte das münchner abkommen sein
das damals ja ein waffenstillstand
vorsah und den abzug schwerer waffen aus
der russisch-ukrainischen grenze region
möglich dass die usa dort neben
deutschland und frankreich als direkter
verhandlungspartner mit eintreten dazu
haben wir aber jetzt aus den
verhandlungen noch nichts gehört die
eben gerade erst zu ende gegangen sind
das ging schon darum ein klares
drohszenario
aufzubauen von scharfen sanktionen war
da die rede die vor allem den finanz-
und energiesektor russlands empfindlich
treffen würden zum beispiel im gespräch
ein ausschluss russischer banken aus dem
internationalen finanzsystems hilft
außerdem sanktionen gegen betreiber und
beteiligte der nord stream pipeline oder
dort könnte sogar ganz der stecker
gezogen werden das heißt das ging schon
darum putin vor augen zu führen welchen
preis er zahlen müsste wenn er die
ukraine angreift präsident biden möchte
jetzt heute noch mit den europäischen
partnern den nato partnern darunter auch
deutschland sprechen um sich hier ganz
genau weiter zu koordinieren
also das wird uns noch länger
beschäftigen danke nach washington
claudia bates jetzt nochmal zum corona
thema in thüringen und vor allem in
sachsen haben gestern trotz verbots
wieder tausende gegen die korona
maßnahmen protestiert rund 1000
versammelten sich in freiberg erlaubt
sind 10 die polizei stoppte die aufzüge
dort und auch anderswo leitete verfahren
unter anderem wegen widerstandes gegen
vollstreckungsbeamte und beleidigung
und viele teilnehmer dieser vermeintlich
spontanen versammlungen haben sich
vorher im online-dienst telegramm
verabredet mit telegramm kann man
nachrichten auf smartphones auf tablets
und pcs verschicken kontrollen oder
staatliche eingriffe gibt es da
eigentlich nicht und darum wird diese
app zum beispiel auch von
oppositionellen in totalitären systemen
genutzt aber eben auch von radikalen
corona leugnern die frontal reporter
arndt ginzel und christian rohde haben
in der szene recherchiert
vor wenigen wochen treten wir unter
falschen namen einer telegramm gruppe
bei dresden offline vernetzung so können
wir audio chats mit höheren hier lehnen
sie impfungen den staat und seine corona
politik ab
die gruppe hat mehr als 100 mitglieder
der mutmaßliche administrator daniel hat
sich angeblich bewaffnet
[Musik]
vor 14 tagen verabredet der harte kern
ein konspiratives treffen wir drehen
verdeckt daniel der mutmaßliche anführer
mit einem mitstreiter
wir können nur aus großer distanz firmen
es wird nacht am tag darauf wird bei
telegramm klar worum es ging
allein treffen gesagt
[Musik]
mordpläne gegen den sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten michael kretschmer
formuliert auf telegramm hier wird hass
hetze und
polemik betrieben insofern sind diese
medien ganz entscheidende mobilizy toren
die sozusagen das ganze noch einmal
verschärfen vergangenen samstag neun
mitglieder der gruppe treffen sich
erneut diesmal bei tageslicht wir
konfrontieren sie am parkplatz
sie wollen ihren ministerpräsidenten
umbringen weil das jetzt nur eine gewalt
fantasie oder oder oder besorgte
zunächst gegen kommentar einen tag
später ist der telegramm kanal nicht
mehr öffentlich einsehbar der
administrator hat ihn auf privat
gestellt
spannende einblicke in eine sehr
spezielle szene und mehr dazu erfahren
sie in frontal heute im zdf um 21 uhr
wegen der korona pandemie werden die
nobelpreise nicht in stockholm verliehen
sondern in den heimatländern der
preisträger in diesem fall heute abend
in berlin
der hamburger forscher klaus hesselmann
bekam den physik nobelpreis für modelle
zum erdklima die urkunde und medaille
für den chemie nobelpreis erhielt auch
benjamin list aus mülheim an der ruhr
für seine arbeiten zur beschleunigung
chemischer reaktionen
von chemischen jetzt zu sportpolitischen
reaktionen da gab es ein dickes
ausrufezeichen der usa und das färbt
jetzt wohl absolut die usa wollen die
kommenden olympischen winterspiele im
februar in china diplomatisch
boykottieren das heißt keine
regierungsvertreter nach peking schicken
unter anderem wegen
menschenrechtsverletzungen im land eine
nation zieht bereits nach und auch der
druck auf die neue deutsche regierung
wächst stetig
weltweit gibt es reaktionen auf die
ankündigung der us-regierung einen
diplomatischen boykott der winterspiele
in peking zu vollziehen die rufe nach
einer beteiligung deutschlands werden
lauter so fordert der außenpolitische
sprecher der grünen omid nouripour das
was die amerikaner sagen dass keine
regierungsmitglieder daran teilnehmen
das halte ich für eine richtige
herangehensweise ich hoffe dass sich
deutschland dem anschließt neuseeland
folgt dem vorstoß der us amerikaner
bereits keine offiziellen vertreter nach
peking zu entsenden die neue
regierungskoalition in deutschland wird
dem us boykott jedoch vorerst nicht
folgen der künftige bundeskanzler will
zunächst
friedlich mit und
trocken doch trotz aller diskussionen
stellt das ioc heute auf einer
pressekonferenz klar er wünschte uns
respekt von der politik und möglichst
wenig einmischung in unsere olympische
welt und deren ideale
die unpolitischen spiele waren in ihrer
geschichte immer wieder politisch
angeheizt es ist wohl erst der beginn
einer großen diskussion der verein
athleten deutschland verdeutlicht indes
der boykott dürfe nicht zulasten der
aktiven sportler gehen
bvb-profi tube bellingham muss für seine
vieldiskutierte schiedsrichterschelte
eine strafe von 40.000 euro zahlen das
hat das dfb-sportgericht entschieden
bellingham hatte nach dem spiel seiner
dortmunder am samstag gegen die bayern
schiedsrichter zweier in einem interview
für die in seinen augen zahlreichen
fehlentscheidungen verbal attackiert und
deutschlands handballerinnen haben bei
der wm in spanien auch ihr letztes
vorrundenspiel gewonnen aber es war ein
hartes stück arbeit dieses 25 24 gegen
ungarn
gerechtfertigter jubel nach dem ersten
echten härtetest man hat natürlich
gesehen dass heute schon der stärkste
vorrunden gegner auf uns gewartet hat
und
ja wir haben es aber geburt vor allem in
der ersten halbzeit beweist die deutsche
mannschaft kampfgeist wie hier michael
schmelzer beim 5 zu 3 zur pause liegt
das team von herrn brüner sogar 14 zu 9
vorne die zweite hälfte dann
ausgeglichen ungarn kommt ran doch das
deutsche team zeigt nervenstärke und
rettet den knappen vorsprung von 25 zu
morgen abend dann erst seit das erste
hauptrundenspiel gegen die republik
kongo hauptsache gebucht hauptsache
danke katja schneeglätte kurzum winter
das erwartete uns aber auch ein bisschen
sonnenschein wo und warum und wieso
diese ganzen fragen klärt dann katja
oliver gleichem wetter wir empfehlen
später marietta slomka und das heute
journal um 21 uhr 45 das gesamte heute
team der 19 uhr bedankt sich für das
interesse wir wünschen noch einen
entspannten abend und freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder dabei sind man es ist
gut
[Musik]
guten abend aus diesem unscheinbaren
wolken klecks über dem atlantik hat sich
innerhalb von nur 24 stunden ein
orkantief entwickelt und seien kernburg
lag heute nachmittag bei 957 hektopascal
und dieses orkantief hat auch einfluss
auf unser wetter mit regen und mit
schnee dieses schnee und regen band
zieht im laufe der nacht weiter ostwärts
und erreicht bis morgen früh
nordfriesland und franken glatt kann es
auf den straßen aber wieder eigentlich
überall seien bei tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen plus vier und minus acht grad
und morgen wird es dann gefährlich aus
der schweiz heraus da kamen nämlich neue
schnee schneeregen und glatteis
regenfälle heran die breiten sich über
baden württemberg und bayern bis nach
thüringen aus die sonne bekommen sie
morgen allerdings auch mal zu gesicht
hier im östlichen sachsen auch in
brandenburg sowie richtung ostfriesland
und niederrhein die temperaturen dazu
liegen morgen meist zwischen minus ein
und plus drei grad wärmer wird zwischen
bremen und basel mit fünf bis sieben
grad und am donnerstag schneit es dann
ergiebig im osten und danach scheint
genau dort die sonne es bleibt insgesamt
winterlich kalt guten abend